NARRATOR: In 2011, it was
declared that Afghanistan
was one of the most
dangerous places in the world
to be a woman.
But that wasn't always the case.
In the 1960s and early
'70s, Afghanistan
was often viewed
as more progressive
than neighboring countries
when it came to women's rights.
Back then, women were able to
pursue an education, get a job,
and even vote.
But when Islamic fundamentalists
group, the Taliban,
seized control of the
country in the mid '90s,
everything changed.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: Why are women
treated the way they are?
A lot of it is the culture.
A culture that's existed
for so many years.
NARRATOR: That was Paula
Bronstein, a photojournalist
who has spent the last
15 years documenting life
in Afghanistan, with a
particular focus on women,
a group that is once again
finding its voice as it strives
to distance itself from
the Taliban's ideology.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: This is a
very conservative culture
in terms of Islam and the
thoughts and the feelings
about what kind of presence
a woman has in society.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: When the
Taliban took over in 1996,
a strict version of
Islamic Sharia law
was imposed across Afghanistan.
With a number of specifically
aimed at stripping away
the fundamental human
rights of women and girls,
bans were imposed on women.
They couldn't even leave the
house without a male chaperone,
and were required to a burqa so
as not to show any bare skin.
Disobeying these laws often
meant brutal punishment,
and the fear of reciprocation
is still so great
that some women have continued
to abide by these laws
even though the Taliban was
ousted from power back in 2001.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: They
were so programmed
to not being seen,
hiding behind the burqa,
and then somehow feeling like
even my camera can x-ray them.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: This was
a challenge for Paula.
However, over time,
she eventually
started to gain
their confidence.
PAULA BRONSTEIN:
In Afghanistan you
sit down to have tea, that's
how you discuss everything.
That's how you get
to know people.
It's the culture.
Me being a female
photojournalist means I can get
a certain kind of access that
perhaps male photojournalist
cannot.
NARRATOR: Paula's
unique access allowed
her to document a
side of Afghan life
that is rarely seen by the West.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: There
were so many women's issues
to document, and stories
to be told-- poverty,
forced marriages, many of
them being child brides,
the abuse that goes on
within the household
that nobody sees-- physical
abuse, mental abuse,
domestic violence in general.
No one felt it was important
to have an educated woman,
so quite a few of
them are illiterate.
NARRATOR: Low levels of
literacy and old social stigmas
that around the idea
of working women
meant that the majority
of Afghan families
rely almost exclusively
on a man's income.
However, the number of wars
over the last three decades
has meant that many women
have been left widowed
and without a household income.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: What happens
to women who don't have
a male who dictates their life?
All of the sudden there's
a uneducated woman who
has to try to feed her kids.
How is she doing it?
Women's issue, here's
the legacy of the war,
the country has got so
many permanent scars.
NARRATOR: During her
time in Afghanistan,
Paula did document
some cultural shifts
in favor of women's rights.
In 2014 she took these photos
of young women rallying
for Ashraf Ghani during
the presidential elections.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: I
really love the fact
that women have-- they
were in huge numbers,
without burqas, waving
flags, and it was just
kind of a joyous occasion.
I loved the energy of the
women that were-- they
had come out to vote,
they were at rallies,
they were just really involved.
I felt like that's a positive--
kind of a positive sign.
NARRATOR: And there
are other signs
that things might be
changing, albeit slowly.
There are still many obstacles.
The Taliban continues to
be a strong presence here,
and longstanding social
stigmas about women's rights
are still a problem.
For Paula, it's hard
to gauge how long it
will take for Afghan women to
truly stand on equal footing
with men.
But she does believe that the
spirit to make that change does
exist among the
women she has met.
PAULA BRONSTEIN: They really
do show amazing amounts
of stamina and just
pure passion to do
what they want to do in life.
NARRATOR: The Taliban
still has strongholds
in parts of Afghanistan.
To find out what it's really
like for American soldiers
deployed to these
regions, take a look
at Discovery's
new series, Taking
Fire, premiering September
13th at 10:00, 9:00 central.